Chinese companies have struggled to
enter the Indian Electronics
manufacturing Market due to increasing
political tensions between the two
countries now Delhi appears to be
warming up to the idea and it's setting
boundaries
according to reports Chinese investors
will have to partner up with local firms
to enter the market the deals will clear
on the condition that the Indian parties
retain a majority stake the government
is now trying to identify 50 to 60
Indian companies to enter such
agreements not just with Chinese
counterparts but also with companies
from South Korea Taiwan and Vietnam
let's go to charu katake to talk about
this it sounds like India is using
China's rules on foreign firms by
setting quite a lot of conditions for
the Chinese doing business in India
well when you know these conditions make
sense only from the perspective of uh
India's stress to my India's focus on
promoting its own manufacturing domestic
manufacturing here and especially in the
electronics sector now Electronics
manufacturing is one of India's weak
points but now it has recently set
itself a an ambitious Target for in the
next about two years but then uh India's
relationship with China as everyone
knows has been deteriorating uh for um
in the last two years after the India
China border standoff so uh this is very
preliminary only this is only at the
proposal stage and media reports suggest
that government is still considering
these proposals one or two Indian
companies are in talks with Chinese
manufacturers to go ahead to set up this
kind of a joint venture but nothing has
been announced at the policy level so
far Ben
Willie do you still have the upper hand
though in these joint ventures
well that's what is
what is for the entry of
Korean firms or Taiwanese firms in in
the Indian Electronics manufacturing
sector will only be allowed if they have
a joint venture with an Indian company
and the Indian company must have a
majority stake in that joint venture so
definitely the plan is to uh is to give
an upper hand to Indian companies and uh
what reports also seem to be suggesting
that this is mostly about transfer of
high-end technology uh which Indian
companies lack and which Chinese
companies Taiwanese Korean company
specialize in so about the transfer of
high-end technology the idea is to give
Indian companies an upper hand
definitely yes Bank the Chinese aren't
the only ones looking to India though
American companies Apple for example is
looking at shifting production from
China to India
um what about India's growing
relationship with China could that
become a stumbling block or a problem
for other foreign investors interested
in India
well so far India is moving carefully
but then it has been exploring all its
options uh the uh the Apple
manufacturing JB is already in place and
it is uh reports suggests that it is
about to begin in in a very short time
and apart from that it is not just China
but it is Taiwan but it is it is South
Korean manufacturers also that India is
considering allowing entry now India is
sort of you know hesitating from putting
all its eggs in one basket so uh various
options are being considered uh at a
policy level U.S has been showing some
uh unpleasant unhappiness with the fact
that India has been partnering with
countries whom the U.S doesn't see eye
to eye with but again Ben as this is
this is at a very preliminary level uh
no clear indications have come whether
this is going to upset other partners as
well but India as you know for the last
several months has been uh has been
showing very deep confidence in its
ability to take multiple partners
together Ben
thank you very much for the analysis